today we're going to talk about some natural beta
blockers now what is a beta blocker well a beta
blocker is something that inhibits or blocks beta
adrenergic receptors which are certain receptors
for adrenaline so basically it blocks the stress
response which is part of the sympathetic nervous
system and doctors prescribe beta blockers for
various conditions number one to help slow down
the heartbeat for abnormal heartbeats arrhythmias
for high blood pressure for second heart attacks
for angina which is chest pain for essential
tremors if your hands are shaking and the word
essential means unknown cause so they don't know
what causes this type of tremor also mitral valve
prolapse and a condition called pots
where you get dizzy if you stand up
and it's been used for anxiety as well
all right so the problem is there are some
side effects from taking a beta blocker so i'm
going to talk about some natural beta blockers
which are certain remedies to reduce adrenaline
now of course adrenaline is part of the stress
response so anything you can do to reduce stress
be a very good thing so the first thing i'm
going to recommend is potassium to increase
your potassium potassium is a physiological
tranquilizer it calms the nervous system down
number two garlic garlic has properties to
reduce blood pressure and it can also help reduce
adrenaline also garlic is loaded with vitamin b1
which is another remedy thiamine b1 is a great
natural remedy to help lower the stress response
it can reduce both cortisol and adrenaline then we
have magnesium which is another mineral that helps
calm the nervous system and by the way
calcium is not something you want to
take if you're trying to lower adrenaline
it can increase adrenaline because calcium
is part of the contraction mechanism whereas
magnesium is part of the relaxation mechanism
all right the next one is vitamin d vitamin
d is really good to help reduce cortisol
as well as adrenaline as part of the stress
response and a great herb to take which is an
adaptogen for the adrenals which can help reduce
cortisol as well as adrenaline is ashwagandha
now the next thing i would highly recommend to
do is do long walks okay every day it's going to
help calm the nervous system down it's going to
help reduce stress increase oxygen and i would
recommend doing my acupressure if you're not
familiar with it i put a link down below of how
to do it but it can help reduce stress and calm
the nervous system which adrenaline is a part of
so if you're enjoying my content which i hope
you are and you're applying this knowledge
to your health and you have a success i would
really appreciate you sharing your success droid
so click the link down below
to my website where you can
upload your success story so
you can help inspire others